das ufer hat sich weit zurückgezogen die
sonne den boden ausgelaugt tiefe risse
durchziehen den grund
wir sind im hinterland von málaga
der stausee la vella wichtig der
wasserspeicher der südspanischen provinz
ist nur noch zu elf prozent gefüllt er
sollte der region einst reichtum bringen
nun ist kaum etwas zu holen der e-motor
sie verliert so viel wasser es kommt
nichts nach es regnet es wird immer
weniger
auf dem trockenen liegen die stege wo
sich sonst touristen tummeln die boote
von elena sanchez waren dieses jahr noch
gar nicht im wasser die reiseleiterin
bietet kajaktouren angst denn da felling
und vieles mehr für uns erfüllt sie ihr
bootshaus
das ist sehr traurig die sind trocken
aber sie sollten nach sein und täglich
gewaschen werden das ist das erste mal
in meinen acht jahren gehe dass sich
diese aktivitäten nicht anbieten kann
vergangenen sommer noch warfen sie vor
der hütte nachmittags zusammen spielten
hier die kinder der serie reichte bis zu
der unteren baureihe zeigt elena der
anblick die ruhe bedrücken sie sie hofft
inständig auf regen und hat ihr programm
geändert bietet nun mehrtagestouren an
früher die region ist reichhaltig wir
haben strände felsenhöhle naturparks
berge es gibt viel zu entdecken
geschichte und gastronomie noch kommen
die touristen
die dörfer rund um den see sind beliebte
ausflugsziele
briten belgier deutsche kommen von der
nahegelegenen küste hierher vor vier
jahren ist christoph fahrt nach
andalusien ausgewandert so trocken wie
jetzt
dann im frühjahr und sommer holt dass
ich eigentlich und das war eigentlich so
irgendwie zu krasseste paula jammers
hilft im restaurant ihres verlobten aus
sie ist im dorf aufgewachsen und macht
sich nun sorgen um die zukunft sollte
die trockenheit weiter anhalten denn
neben dem tourismus ist die
landwirtschaft der größte
wirtschaftsfaktor der region ihr vater
baut avocados an
wenn gar kein wasser mehr im stausee
wäre könnte man auch nicht felder nicht
mehr gießen alles würde vertrocknen und
viele familien hier leben von den
plantagen sie müssten sich dann wohl
eine andere arbeit zu tun
immer mehr pflanzen verdorren schon
jetzt in der not greifen einige bauern
zu drastischen mitteln opfern alte bäume
damit die anderen ausreichend wasser
bekommen ein kilo avocados eigentlich
eine trockenfrucht verschlingt 800 bis
1000 liter hier befindet sich eine der
größten anbauflächen europas
die monokultur treibe die region an den
kollaps erzählt uns der ökologe raphael
hughes erst jetzt sein wasser sparpläne
aktiviert worden zu spät um das
reservoir zu retten
das ist nicht von einem auf das andere
jahr passiert das ist das ergebnis von
mehreren jahren in denen zu viel wasser
für die landwirtschaft entnommen wurde
das zusammen mit der tatsache dass es
nicht genug geregnet hat führt nun dazu
dass der wasserspiegel immer weiter
sinkt bis zu dem punkt an dem nichts
mehr übrig bleibt
ein anders hat sich deswegen für einen
neuen weg entschieden auf seiner finca
arbeitet er mit dem start up unternehmer
ernesto rico zusammen er hat ein system
für effizientes tiefen entwickelt es
bringt das wasser nicht nur direkt zu
den wurzeln die abgabe lässt sich durch
solche kapseln kontrollieren so wird
kein tropfen verschwendet
momente wo ich drehe meine monaten und
gucke ob das wasser auch wirklich
fließen das ist der vorteil dieses
systems
die unterirdische bewässerung gibt es
schon länger aber ich wusste nie wie
viel wasser ankommt
jose hat damit seinen wasserverbrauch
halbiert dennoch wird er einen teil
seiner ernte verlieren allein wegen der
lang anhaltenden hitze in diesem jahr
unbegreiflich wieder einige immer noch
den klimawandel leugnen und
die trockenheit ist ein problem aber
dank der trockenheit entwickelt sich ein
neues bewusstsein an sparsameren
bewässerungs methoden zu forschen
im frühjahr hatte er nur 20 kunden in
diesem sommer kamen mehr als 300 hinzu
auch auswanderer christoph probiert
neues aus er zeigt uns seinen garten und
seine erfindungen versucht das klima für
sich zu nutzen etwa mit diesem trocken
automat also hier geht die sonne rein
hinzu steigt hoch und wird dann
sozusagen die sachen werden hier
getroffen feigen tomaten granatäpfel der
familie ist es wichtig sich auf die
mediterrane vielfalt zu besinnen in
einklang mit der natur zu leben
wir sind im moment an seinem an so einem
jahrhundertereignis einen meilenstein
was auch immer wo eben einfach
gewerkschaft umdenken muss um eben ja
weiter eben hat sich dramatisch an
existieren zu können auf der welt
es ist ein sommer der nachdenklich
stimmt der wassermangel wird hier in la
villa zur existenzkrise rettender regen
ist nicht in sicht meteorologen warnen
dass die dürrezeiten in spanien künftig
noch öfter austreten werden
[Musik]